OF NEXT MONTH.
SANDRA?
>> Sandra: THANK YOU.
>> Ed: AS WE PAUSE TO REMEMBER
OUR BRAVE SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN,
THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS IS DEALING WITH A TOUGH
ISSUE.
MOST MEMORIAL DAY IS ONLINE, DUE
TO PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS.
ONE FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN IS
OBJECTING, AN ARMY VET WRITING
THIS, "WITH MANY PARTS OF OUR
COUNTRY NOW IN THE PROCESS OF A
PHASE REOPENING, I FIND IT
APPALLING THAT BEACHES WILL BE
OPEN FOR THE HOLIDAY BUT ACCESS
TO VA CEMETERIES WILL REMAIN
RESTRICTED.
SO THE SECRETARY OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS IS JOINING US LIVE NOW,
GOOD MORNING, SIR.
>> GOOD MORNING, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME.
>> Ed: I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO RESPOND TO THAT, BUT I
WOULD BE REMISS TO NOT START BY
GIVING YOU A CHANCE TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT IT’S LIKE TO SERVE
THIS GREAT NATION HAS A VA
SECRETARY AS THE PRESIDENT LEADS
THE NATION IN MARKING THIS
MEMORIAL DAY.
>> AS SOME OF YOU KNOW, I AM THE
SON OF A GRIEVOUSLY WOUNDED
COMBAT SOLDIER.
I STILL SERVE IN THE AIR FORCE
RESERVE, MY EARLIEST MEMORIES
AREN’T ELEMENTARY IN
KINDERGARTEN, AND I’VE OFTEN
SAID THAT WHEN A CLASSMATE WAS
CALLED TO THE PRINCIPAL’S OFFICE
DURING THOSE TIMES IN MY YOUTH,
THERE WAS ALWAYS A CHANCE THAT
THAT CHILD WASN’T GOING TO A
DOCTOR’S APPOINTMENT, THAT IT
WAS BAD NEWS FROM SOUTHEAST
ASIA.
SO I WAS ABLE TO SEE THIS
THROUGH THE EYES OF A CHILD NOT
ONLY WITH MY FATHER’S RECOVERY
COME UP THE LOSS OF SO MANY OF
HIS COMRADES PARTICULARLY AT
FORT BRAGG, THE HOME OF SPECIAL
FORCES AND OF COURSE THE HOME OF
THE 82ND AIRBORNE DIVISION.
THE ONE THING I ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT, AND I’VE SAID THIS TODAY
AT QUANTICO NATIONAL CEMETERY,
THE ONE THING THAT SEPARATES THE
AMERICAN WARRIOR FROM ALL OTHER
FIGHTING FORCES IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WORLD IS THAT WE ARE THE
ONLY PEOPLE TO OFFER A HELPING
HAND TO ALL THE PEOPLES OF THE
WORLD INCLUDING OUR ENEMIES, AND
AS GENERAL POWELL SAID SO
ELOQUENTLY, THE ONLY THING WE
EVER ASK IS A PLACE TO BURY OUR
DEAD, AND I THINK THAT’S A
FITTING MEMORIAL TO ALL OF THE
OVER 1 MILLION AMERICANS WHO
HAVE PERISHED SINCE THE FIRST
SHOTS WERE FIRED IN LEXINGTON IN
APRIL OF 1775.
>> Ed: VERY WELL SAID, AS WE
TALK ABOUT THOSE WHO ARE BURIED,
IT’S A DIFFICULT SUBJECT
OBVIOUSLY IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
PANDEMIC ABOUT WHAT TO DO TO
GIVE PEOPLE A CHANCE TO HONOR
THE DEAD.
SO WE MENTIONED HE’S A WARRIOR
HIMSELF AS YOU KNOW, HE WAS
GRIEVOUSLY WOUNDED AS WELL, A
VETERAN, AND HIS POINT IS IN THE
LETTER THAT AMERICANS SHOULD
HAVE THE FREEDOM TO MOURN AND
PAY THEIR RESPECTS IN THE MANNER
THEY JUDGE IS BEST FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR GROUPS.
SO TALK ABOUT WHY YOU DECIDED
WE’VE GOT TO CLOSE OFF THE VA
CEMETERY, WHAT OTHER WAYS ARE
YOU OFFERING FOR PEOPLE TO MOURN
AND WHAT YOU THINK THEY MAY
ULTIMATELY SAY?
>> LET ME DO SOMETHING HARD AND
CORRECT THE CONGRESSMAN.
WE HAVE 142 VA CEMETERIES, NOT
ONE OF THEM HAS EVER CLOSED
DURING THIS EPIDEMIC.
I JUST SPOKE AT THE QUANTICO
NATIONAL CEMETERY, AND AS I WAS
SPEAKING, I WAS LOOKING OUT AT
FAMILIES COLLECTING TO
MEMORIALIZE THEIR LOVED ONES.
THAT’S HAPPENING ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
WHAT WE HAD STOPPED WHERE
GATHERINGS OF LARGE GROUPS LIKE
THE BOY SCOUTS.
IN FACT, HE ISSUED A STATEMENT
EARLIER LAST WEEK WITH THE
BOY SCOUT LEADERSHIP BECAUSE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
BOY SCOUTS WOULD HAVE BEEN AN
ERROR CEMETERIES PLANTING FLAGS,
THE SCOUT LEADERSHIP DECIDED IN
TERMS OF SAFETY FOR THEM THAT
THEY WOULD HONOR VETERANS
THROUGH A VIRTUAL CELEBRATION
AND TODAY, 3:00 ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, SCOUTS WILL PARTICIPATE
IN OUR VETERANS LEGACY PROJECT,
AND THEY WILL BE STANDING AT
ATTENTION AS THE BUGLER BLOWS
"TAPS" AND SALUTES.
IN SANDRA’S LEAD INTO THE
CEREMONY AT ARLINGTON, SHE NOTED
THAT THE ARLINGTON NATIONAL
CEMETERY WHICH IS RUN BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE ARMY FOR THE
PRESIDENT WAS TODAY, THE
FAMILIES WERE THERE, THE
FAMILIES WHERE THEY ARE DOING
WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT, AND THAT
IS MEMORIALIZING AND REMEMBERING
THEIR LOVED ONES, AND I THINK OF
ALL THE THINGS THAT WE DO, THAT
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT, THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF WHAT WE
GIVE TO THE NATION, AND THEY
WERE ABLE TO PERFORM THOSE
SACRED RESPONSIBILITIES.
>> Ed: RESTRICTED, THE
CONGRESSMAN IS SAYING.
HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY THAT, THAT
FAMILIES HAVE RESTRICTED ACCESS
TO THESE CEMETERIES?
>> THE FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS,
THAT’S THE KEY, AND THEY’VE ALSO
HAD ACCESS WHEN WE’VE HAD OUR
BURIALS, AND THOSE BURIALS HAVE
BEEN GOING ON ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, BUT I WILL WOULD ALSO N
THIS WAS HINTED IN THE ARLINGTON
PEAS.
WE HAVEN’T HAD THE BENEFIT OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE HONOR
GUARDS, THOSE HAVE BEEN STOPPED
FOR SAFETY REASONS.
WE WILL RETURN OUR CEMETERIES TO
FULLY USE VERY SHORTLY, AND IT
IS A TRAGEDY IN ONE SENSE THAT
WE HAVEN’T BEEN ALLOWED TO BRING
MASSES OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
INTO OUR CEMETERIES AS LONG AS
THE FAMILIES ARE ALLOWED TO GO,
THAT’S THE MOST IMPORTANT PART
OF WHAT WE DO.
>> Ed: IT CERTAINLY IS AND HE
WAS A YOUNG BOY DEALING WITH IT,
AND SOME KIDS BEING CALLED TO
THE PRINCIPAL’S OFFICE TO FIND
OUT THAT THEY’VE LOST A MOM OR
DAD OR AN UNCLE OR AUNT, WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR